[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Miss Argentina and Miss Puerto Rico are
married
[Music]
former Miss Argentina and Fabiola
Valentin former Miss Puerto Rico
revealed they secretly tied the knot
after privately dating for two years the
beauty queens originally met in 2020
while competing in the Miss Grand
International pageant
Argentina
[Applause]
two years later the pair confirmed their
relationship and marriage in a joint
Instagram reel
alongside the video the women wrote
after deciding to keep our relationship
private we opened the doors to them on a
special day the compilation of Clips
which has already amassed over 2 million
views gives fans a glimpse into the
couple's many travels and the night they
got engaged let me tell you more about
myself
I love to create great connection with
people during her time in the Miss Grand
International competition Mariana let
viewers see her fun side and I always
have a great sense of humor and positive
attitude to White challenges because I
think this is the best way to face life
while also getting serious and sharing
the importance of spreading peace
violence has many faces and they go with
19 showed us that there isn't a space
for the lack of empathy and their
respect
apathy
we can have different opinions and I
don't need to live with them but I must
respect them
respect make us worthy of evolution
Fabiola shared a similar sentiment in
Her speech throughout history warlike
and violent conflicts have been seen as
a means to achieve something although
time has shown us that much more is lost
peace is more than just the offices of
war and violent conflicts it is also the
opportunity for all to have a social
realities and write this in life
regardless of the race religion gender
or color neither of the women took the
grand title in the pageant but they did
leave the competition winners finding
love and getting their happily ever
after
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]